[Music]
so the rapper de baby
has uh i can't even say his name without
laughing
uh the rapper the baby dub i don't know
how to emphasize
duh baby the baby the rapper de babias
found himself in the middle of a
full-blown pr
pr crisis stemming from comments he made
at a concert recently
and by the way please don't confuse the
baby with little baby or
say to baby or bad baby these are all
different people different babies i
think
uh the baby is is is the one who's in
trouble now because he used anti-gay
slurs during a concert
in miami recently at one point during
the show
he called for people who don't have hiv
to put their cell phone lights up
uh now if you haven't been to a concert
since 2005 just you know the cell phone
light has replaced the lighter
so you know you put that up like like
people used to put lighters up at
concerts he also called for men who
haven't performed certain sexual acts on
other men in the parking lot
to put their cell phone lights up it
isn't clear why he said this or
why he brought it up but it would appear
to be some kind of joke that he made
and the joke did not land quickly other
artists came out and condemned the baby
young artists like dua lipa whoever that
is
i don't know i can't even say these
people's names
um and old artists like elton john and
madonna also came out many others spoke
out to chastise the baby
and uh put him in time out like so many
babies before him and then the financial
penalties really kicked in
lollapalooza dropped him from their
lineup
i heart radio festival dropped him he
was dumped by austin city limits and the
governor's ball
he was banned from performing at his
cousin's birthday party
uh the point is he he quickly became
persona non grata across the music
industry
now the baby tried to satiate the mob by
addressing the situation on instagram in
the immediate aftermath
his remarks were and we'll play them for
you i think you'll agree they're they're
quite eloquent
and uh and worth listening to let's
listen
one time i'm gonna get back to giving my
love to my fans
that's what i'm saying because what me
and my fans do at the live show it don't
concern you
on the internet or you better on the
internet it's not your business
you know what i'm saying like what i do
at a live show is for the audience
at the live show it'll never translate
correctly to somebody
looking at a little five six second clip
from korea
on a phone it just don't work like that
like
you know because regardless of what you
know talking about how the internet and
twisted up my mother me and all my fans
at the show
the gay ones and the straight ones we
turned up i'm telling
my boy that was at the front of stage
left over there by where i jumped at ask
him he got
clips all on his the whole night was
recording we were turning the whole
night
my boy had the crop top on front row
yeah out there in that jungle in that
water
yeah he out there he's standing on the
rail got them cutting up
words i saw him i'm wrapping him with
him
indeed it is not your business
and he raises a good point i mean there
was a guy with a crop top in the front
row
and he was turned what else do you want
the guy with the crop top was turned so
it's not your business
end of discussion except it was not the
end of discussion shockingly the
statement that
he released there didn't do anything to
quell the outrage
so he tried again with a written
statement and full apology
i'll read this statement to you and i
don't know it just sounds a little bit
different
from what we just heard there in
instagram but uh i don't know you tell
me he said this is what was the
statement that was published from
the baby social media moves so fast that
people want to demolish you before you
even have the opportunity to grow
educate and learn from your mistakes as
a man who has made his own way
from very difficult circumstances having
people i know publicly working against
me
knowing that what i needed was that
education on these topics and guidance
has been challenging i appreciate the
many people who came to me with kindness
who reached out to me privately to offer
wisdom
education and resources that's what i
needed and it was received
i want to apologize to the lgbtq plus
community
for the hurtful and triggering comments
i made again i apologize for my
misinformed comments about hiv
aids and i know education on this is
important
love to all god bless now
now if i know the baby and i don't know
him but still
you know i don't think he wrote that i'm
guessing he is not the one who wrote the
phrase
i apologize to the lgbtq plus community
for the hurtful and triggering comments
but whoever wrote it it was not enough
the baby has crossed a line that you
can't cross these days which is
interesting because it's not as though
those comments about gay people were the
first objectionable things he's ever
said in his life
his songs you know the songs that these
music festivals have hired him to come
and perform
are each a succession of one
objectionable statement after another
in fact those songs the songs that again
the music festivals
hired him to perform perform and then
banned him from performing
contains statements and ideas that are
far more outrageous and offensive than
anything he said about hiv or gay people
he actively promotes murder drug dealing
violent crime of all sorts the
objectification and murder of women
among other things
just one verse on one song will likely
likely contain all of these things
for example one of his biggest singles
is a song called shug which is an
homage to uh suge knight who's the
murderous former ceo of death row
records
who's now serving time in a maximum
security prison
for running a guy down in his car and
killing him
and the song lives up to its namesake
i'll play a quick clip just to give you
an idea
of uh of what this guy is all about
let's let's play this
pack in the middle it's gone
[Music]
[Music]
truly a masterpiece and you know the
editors love me when i send them stuff
like that
here you go guys spend the next 15 hours
editing this
to get all the customers up um if you
weren't able to understand anything
there
let me run through some of the
highlights here's what he says
the first n-word play i'm a body in
n-word i just check my balance i'll
probably pull up to your hood
get caught with your then i'm popping
them both you disrespect me and i'll
beat you
up in front of your partners and
children take 20k and put that on your
head and make one of your partners come
kill you
uh etc and so forth now to review
in just the first verse of one song he's
killing someone
then killing someone else along with
that guy's girlfriend
then he's assaulting someone in front of
their children and then he's putting a
hit out on someone else
and later in that song he blows
someone's head off
shoots somebody in front of their
grandmother and has sex with various
in his words not mine he also said that
he also seems to brag about having sex
with a girl in grade school
saying that he pulls up after school to
teach her some
now i hope i'm not misinterpreting but i
can only assume he's not bragging about
giving actual math lessons
now um the baby is is not any different
from the average rapper but
does that make it okay to openly
romanticize death and slaughter and
sexual violence
and if you're upset about derogatory
comments about lgbt people
which means you're taking what this guy
says seriously you're holding him to a
certain standard in his speech
then why wouldn't you be upset about
literally everything else he's ever said
in any of his songs just consider the
absolute absurdity of a baby fan
singing along as he talks about shooting
hoes in the face and then going whoa
whoa whoa
hey don't be insensitive to lgbt people
the baby
come on have some class young man please
understand something i am not equating
his song lyrics with what he said about
gay people and aids
i would never do that they're not the
same because the song lyrics are a
thousand
times worse they are worse not only in
their content
but in their effect you know the violent
crime problem in our cities is largely
driven by young men
who grew up without fathers in the home
those young men look to guys like the
baby
as role models these rappers are
are are the only male role models that
many of these kids have
so when these role models are standing
in front of them and explicitly saying
hey it's cool to shoot and kill people
if you have a beef with them or even if
you don't
that has an impact that resonates it's
not a coincidence that probably close to
100 percent of the murderers arrested in
the city
in in you know in any given city listen
to rap music
i bet we could comb through every
penitentiary in the country
in the country and and find like two
classical music fans
if that many it's not a matter of rap
music
directly causing violent crime we're
talking about influence
the messages that you pump into your
eardrums every day
will influence you of course they will
and the messages from guys like the baby
are not just negative not just bad
but they're almost absurdly evil
cartoonishly cruel
only the people influenced by them don't
see them as cartoonish
and the rappers themselves don't see it
as cartoonish
only well-adjusted adults can hear these
kinds of songs and find them laughably
ridiculous
the rap fans who were upset about the
baby's comments about gay people
we'll probably hear what i'm saying
right now and scoff insisting that
lyrics are just words and
they don't mean anything they don't have
any real impact
and yet when it comes to the comments
about gay people they certainly do think
it matters
and it does mean something and it does
have an impact
so for them some words are violence and
yet words that literally and directly
encourage violence
are harmless it's completely backwards
and incoherent
and lying at the heart of all this is a
demented and vacuous moral code
which excuses nearly all evil applauds
nearly all sin
except when it upsets a member of the
protected class it's a kind of elitism
except far more morally vacuous than
normal elitism
and for all of those reasons the mob
which is selectively outraged
at the baby is today canceled
and uh the baby is canceled too
but not even because of what he said
about gay people uh i'm more concerned
again about the fact that he's going
around
encouraging people to kill each other
that to me seems like
the bigger issue and so all those people
are canceled today
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now
i thank you for your compliance it is
somewhat appreciated